all right welcome back everyone
um
well we we have the pleasure of hearing
from your ghost pirioras now at the
singapore university of technology and
design they'll tell us about some game
dynamics results on optimal no regret
learning
via clairvoyant multiplicative weights
so
thank you ref
okay
hi everybody yes uh
so today we'll be talking more about uh
learning in games
and actually uh hopefully in some sense
it will be
a natural continuation of the talk that
like sergio uh were just giving and as
you say this is a joint work with ryan
singh and statistics
so ryan is a student and statistic is a
postdoc who's actually just moved to
epfl
okay and
all right so this this work will be
about uh
understanding uh how to achieve
inaudible
the exploration of what no regret means
so by not regret
online algorithms who mean an algorithm
such that
no single action
significantly outperforms the algorithm
of the
dynamic and this notion of regret is uh
effectively we look at the history of t
time periods like
as surgery was saying like maybe the
first year or so
and then we look at the total profit
that the algorithm achieved
and then we compare that with the total
profit of the best fixed action with
hindsight
so
uh and we want so this difference is
exactly what we call regret
and an algorithm is colloquially
characterized as a node grid
if for every possible input sequence
they get growth sublinearly with time
and uh
and based on a classical result going
back to the work of blackboard hanan
we know how to create a general
algorithms in general uh in online
settings that gandhi square
square root of t regret okay and uh
actually this is the best possible
guarantee
this online setting
and to make this uh setting like a
little bit uh more obvious i'll actually
revisit an example that sergio
just told us
like again in the last talk so let's say
you know uh i'm playing this game
against nature
so you know
i'm
every day before i step out of my door i
need to decide whether
you know whether i'll bring my
with me an umbrella or sunscreen
and the thing is that i don't know the
realization of the weather and
beforehand
and then if i make the correct choice
then uh let's get let's say i get a
payoff of one and otherwise i get a
payoff of zero
okay
so this is my setting
and let's say suppose that uh
you know this was the realization of the
of the weather
and then this was the choices made by my
algorithm so we see that uh
i make the correct choice
uh exactly
uh three times so one two three right so
the profit of my algorithm is three
right
but then if i looked at
what would be the profit if i wish those
umbrella then i would see that my profit
for choosing an
umbrella is three right
and then uh if i was to sunscreen my
profit would be equal to one okay
so in this case the regret
for the specific uh instantiation of
this algorithm is zero right because
this is the best uh
uh
the performance of the best fixed action
on hindsight this is my actual
performance of the algorithm
and of course my the other things are
allowed to make a randomized action so i
could say choose
like fifty percent uh uh
uh sunscreen and like with probability
fifty percent like take one with two
actions okay and although this example
is actually very trivial uh in some
sense it's also like suffices to provide
the lower bound so
so for example if the realization of the
weather every day is 50-50 50 okay the
you know in expectation i mean there's
nothing to learn in this kind of setting
every action in expectation will give
you uh an expected payoff of t over two
but you do the variance some action
would be
roughly order square root of t better
right and that's the thing that you
cannot really predict or know and this
this is the
the source of the square root of theory
grid
okay
so although okay this is like a very
simple uh lower bound on the regret but
it was again like really surprising is
that like you know
this uh lower bound is tied and is given
is guaranteed by very simple algorithms
and arguably one of the most typical
class of algorithms i guarantee this
is this class of follow the regularized
follow the regularity of algorithms
okay and these are algorithms that
perform this kind of
exploration exploitation or traders in
the online learning okay so here
we have an algorithm and uh it's
algorithm
every single day
the agent
needs to choose a mixed id okay
and
the mixed strategy
uh will try to maximize the players
expected payoff
minus this uh
some strong convex uh regularization
term okay so
and maximizing the cumulative payoff
leads to this to this
exploitation right so you want to play
with high probability actions that that
have worked well for you right
but uh without this
this regularization term this algorithm
becomes very unstable right because
uh without this regularization on every
single day the probability you know your
algorithm would just choose an actual
probability one right
so by adding some sort like
regularization term you saw like the
algorithm favors like more mixed
strategies and and becomes more uh more
stable over time
okay so here's this
and uh the state of the algorithm here
is is this sort of like vector of
cumulative payoffs right which in some
sense is your memory it's like uh
so it keeps track let's say suppose i i
had two actions choose umbrella you know
or choose a
sunscreen so this would say okay how
much money how much payoff historically
have i received so far for choosing a
bella
how much payoff have i received so far
historically for choosing a sunscreen
okay
and then i just have to solve this uh
simple uh
concave optimization problem to find the
uh my optimal strategy okay
so
now although this uh formulation is
standard in the online learning
literature
uh it's actually sometimes useful to
consider not just the discrete time
version of this algorithm but this
continuous time as well
okay so now the analysis is effectively
more or less
identical the only thing that changes is
that like the time now this does not
move forward in uh discrete time steps
but moves forward in continuous time
okay so now
again i have like a vector of let's say
two outcomes or
m outcomes as many as my actions right
and each of them now keeps track the
historical uh payoff of all of them
for now the payoff is not a summation
but uh an integral okay
but the decision problem that i'm
solving for is exactly the same okay
i'm solving for this like i'm choosing
the mixed strategy that tries to
maximize this inner product
minus this uh
strictly uh convex regularization term
okay
now within this class of follow the
regular steel dynamics
there is a
arguably
one of the most pro typical if not the
most pro typical member
is the class of uh
is the
multiplicative weight update algorithm
which
is derived by this uh ftrl dynamics if
we use the negative entropy as the
regularizer
so this sounds that we already saw uh
already yesterday uh in paragraph stock
and uh you know with my years whenever
we talk about this uh
this object is a is a thorny subject
and the thorny is like what we call the
algorithm
so
it's this so like it's like one joke
that if you look at the literature this
argument has been rediscovered like at
least half a dozen times it comes up
with like many many you know in
different literatures in different like
scientific communities
so it's now also known as aggregating
algorithm heads
exponential gradient
weight majority
exponential weights which i think is uh
panagiotis favorite and so and so forth
okay
and uh and one important thing that was
uh
that was also like uh uh yeah it was
also explored
already is that like this a connection
between uh
that when we're moving in a continuous
time
when you look at the integrals in terms
of summations
then uh this uh the analog of
multiplicative weight updates is this uh
class of ods that's known as the
replicator dynamics
and then again replicated dynamics is a
it's a family of dynamics that has been
studied extensively
within the let's say within mathematical
biology and evolutionary game theory is
arguably maybe the main dynamic of of
this area
okay and now
like we're gonna go a little bit back
and forth between these two
these two somehow like tools and uh
actually a lot of uh our initial
uh you know goal for like you know
pushing for stronger than square root of
t results in terms of regret
comes from this like very simple
argument that's due to uh she venturing
all the way you know back in uh 209
that says it like okay in the case of
replicator dynamics there is almost like
a this is literally like a two-line
proof
that the regret uh actually in any
online setting
uh does not grow with time so you can
actually have like constantly get the
bonds okay so
in some sense continuous time dynamics
are much easier than discrete time
and so here's the again again here's the
dynamic
right that's uh what i've said
like uh so what do we do here is uh
so first we just so let's say x
a is just the probability of choosing
some action a ua
is your utility for choosing action a
right and now i'm just dividing this
probability x of a and i'm taking to the
other side
and the second thing that i'm doing is
i'm just integrating
uh both the left and the right hand of
this equation
and uh i think it's easy to see that in
the interior of this integral you have
the derivative of ln of x
so the derivative and the integral have
cancelled themselves out
and you get this difference so
the difference between ln of x at time t
and at time 0
is equal to this
to this integral
okay
but then again what is
x of a it's just my probability of
choosing some action so x of alpha
it's a probability of choosing some
action alpha so it's a number between
zero and one
so it's a lens it's non-negative right
not positive
sorry and uh i can just remove it
i cannot just get this inequality
okay
but the important thing is that
this integral
on the right hand side
i claim is exactly the object that i
want to
upper bound
so this is exactly my regret
for not deviating and always playing
some action alpha
so let's uh convince
ourselves about that this is indeed the
case
okay so what's the first part in this
integral so this is my utility for
playing uh action alpha all the time so
there's a hidden dependency on time on
all of these terms right
so the integral over this is exactly you
know what is my counter factual
payoff for just playing alpha like all
the time
whereas the other term actually just
gives me my expected utility
my actual expectativity given the
randomized choices that i made at time t
right so
taking integral over that giving my
actual total
aggregated payoff right so
so the difference just the alpha are not
random again yeah right so in principle
i just need to try it once exactly
yes i mean that's the whole point here
this is is so for so you can do this for
any action alpha right so your regret
for
deleting any fixed action is upper
bounded by such a term right
and hence uh also for the maximum
alpha for the best arm hence the total
grit is upper bounded by something that
does not grow with time
right
so of course i mean so okay this is
really great so it's great in two ways
well first of all it's much much you
know better
uh much stronger than what we get in
discrete time right and the proof is
very very simple okay
yes
i might just i can also just try each
action once and then i know what's best
and i'm done
no because i mean
so remember your payoffs change over
time
right so this is not so here you know
i'm just
uh you know like everything here depends
on time i'm just not explicitly writing
that notation because notation will
become very heavy right so this is not
like a fixed
entry right this is not five right so u
of a
it's what's my utility let's say for
playing an umbrella
the first you know on an interval zero
one right
so this is something that like just you
know that evolves in some sort like
arbitrary way but let's say when in the
case of continuous time i need some
integrability right so that this this
uh so this uh
integral somehow like makes sense but
modulo this like everything goes through
okay uh all right great
thank you for the question
and uh of course you know the problem is
that like you know let's say in computer
of course in computer science
like uh
we want things that like run in discrete
time so this is like a very nice
mathematical proof but this is not
something you can actually directly
implement and and build the system based
on top of this right
but uh so so the goal here
is to say like okay but this maybe
define some possible quest you know can
we design
an actual like honest-to-god algorithm
something that runs in discrete time
and achieves constant regret
in general gains
okay
and uh yeah and in this talk we'll
actually show exactly how to do that
okay so
we'll show actually a variant of this
ubiquitous multiplicative weight updates
algorithm that indeed
uh managed to
achieve constant regret in fact boundary
we get in general games
and it only does that but managed to do
that do that with fixed step size
so again remember like the the classical
square root of the regret bound for
getting uh
square root of theoretical
multiplicative weight updates
uh is based on the assumption that your
learning rate decreases at a rate over
one over square root of three and this
is this assumption is like very very
important
so here actually we we go against that
that uh intuition and actually we
we're actually going to define a
different algorithm that we learn with
large step sizes and in fact what is
even more surprising is that like
that step size is good
so the upper bound that will show on the
regret actually will
decrease linearly with the step size
so somehow like the largest the step
size the more aggressive the players
become like the smaller the grid bound
okay
all right so here's the here's the
promise
okay so now let's try to explore okay i
mean in some sense this sounds already
very very surprising like something
totally new must be coming into play and
indeed there is a totally new idea
but the the ideas are like
that online learning and online learning
games is actually two totally different
mathematical objects
so online learning is what is known as
an open loop system now you know jeff
here you know control series is like
okay this is my world
so like uh open loop system is like okay
there's input there's output and
effectively i don't have any control
over the input
the input is like coming from the
weather like it's got it's a totally
adversarial object
okay
but in the case of uh learning in games
that's no longer true
right
so i'm learning everybody else i'm
learning but here is learning raph is
learning right
i'm sorry i'm just a bit confused with
the classification i mean i can
think of very many closed loop
algorithms and very many open group
dynamical systems so i would be confused
about open loop dynamical systems in
continuous time right all right so like
maybe
let's let's okay so let's not get
like to type documentation let me talk
about that by open loop here i mean the
setting of online maybe online
optimization right where there's like
absolutely no constraints on the
sequence of payers that are like that
you're seeing that
in some sense are possibly coming from a
totally adversarial source right
because in the case of closed loop
systems actually in the case of let's
say games
you actually there are some constraints
in what in in in your source of players
so you i'm playing a game versus best
for example like dotie and rough so
they're playing they have some learning
dynamics i i have some learning dynamics
so for example like what happens today
actually affects give us some
information about what will happen
tomorrow
okay
so this is the kind of like somehow
information this is the kind of like
structure
that i'm going to try to exploit to get
to the stronger guarantees
okay so this is uh
the beginning of the intuition right
and now because
okay now we're gonna get a little bit
more technical yes
so what you're assuming is that all the
players are using the same
algorithm yes yes yes a hundred percent
so like as
as i will also show you many other
like prior results in the literature
like all the results come with the
assumption
that people use algorithms from this
class right so if somebody does it
deviates then all bets are off
yes
great
all right so here's now a little bit of
piece of notation right
as we're going to become like a little
bit more technical now okay so
from the for all this talk actually i'll
be talking about
the vanilla formulation of normal games
okay so that means i have a finite
number of agents
each agent has a set of strategies which
also like a finite set
and now each player has a payoff
function ui
that is just a function that given any
strategy profile of the agent just
spits out the payoff of the agent who's
just like a real number
right and of course we allow players to
not display uh pure strategies s but
also like mixed rajs and we'll denote
this
uh by x i so x i is the vector
of the mixed strategy of player i
and x i s i is the probability with
which
agent i plays strategy si
okay
and
the utility now
of course it's extends over profiles of
mixed strategies in the usual somehow
like multilinear way by taking
expectations okay
and
the other piece of notation is like okay
although i will use ui to be
just a scalar which is just a payoff
uh when i have uh the payoff
of an agent at a specific strategy
profile
by vi i will consider
a whole vector okay
and the vector effectively will give me
okay what is
given the mixed edge of all of my
opponents
what is my utility for playing the first
the second the third strategy and so on
and so forth okay so and in this model i
will always
assume that i have access to this
information okay so for example like if
i'm playing rock paper scissors and i
have some
mixed strategy of my opponent let's say
one third one third one third
then this vector vi would be just zero
because the behavior of all of all of
the other agents evolves over time right
the pay of functions
the the yeah
for the yes the payoff functions are not
actually i will see at the very end of
the
like you can actually deal with some
sort like
with change and players but for now
let's say let's just think this in the
classical setting your game is fixed fix
that arbitrary
okay
great but yes thank you for the question
okay so this is just as i said this
annotation vi's are like scalars so uis
are scalar vi's are like vectors okay so
okay and then
here's again the
of course the the standard version of
multiplicative weight updates
okay that we've seen that we've seen
before
and as i said like this is this
corresponds to the
to the case of follow the regularized
leader
where uh
now each player has a specific let's say
learning rate at i okay so
at i and the
regularizer uh hi is just like the
the negative enterprise right and it's a
simple somehow like
like you just solve for kkd conditions
to show indeed that that uh the solution
of this the unique solution of this
system corresponds to this
multiplicative weight updates rule
okay
uh but
now a dynamic that actually becomes
important for this talk
is a recent uh uh
a recent tweak on uh multiplicative
weight updates as known as the
uh optimistic multiplicative weight
updates which
include used by uh
christine scalace and jan's managers
and uh in some sense okay the
now the as you see like in the update
rule
you get something more complicated
okay
but there is a an intuitive way of
thinking about what optimistic
multiplicative weight update does okay
so effectively
each player just applies the standard
multiplicative weight updates dynamic
okay but in their minds they show like
they preempt like one extra step for all
of the other agents okay
so each agent projects in their mind
the other opponent's upcoming behavior
in the next time step okay and say like
okay i'm gonna imagine what they'll play
tomorrow and i will react to that okay
but but this this assumption that they
make
is that
tomorrow
all of the other agents will be exactly
as they play today
okay so in some sense uh they use the
last observed action as a predictor
and in some sense the intuition here
again and then this is somehow like
using the fact that
the system here is closed
all right so if
the learning rate of the agent of all of
the agents is a really really small
number
then this is like a very reasonable
assumption right
so not players are effectively making us
a minor a very small chains right
and an order of eta chains to their
mixture i exist right
so the players that i'm getting the
payoff vector will be very close to what
i actually got today okay so i'm going
to take advantage of that right and i'm
going to do it in my mind
and everybody does that simultaneously
okay does that make sense
so again like a very very reasonable
trick okay
uh and amazingly okay this is just very
yes
right
from this equation i'm not sure about
the intuition about the last observed
action because it seems that what you
add is actually the difference
between
vxt and vxt
all right there's another way okay i
won't do
the
you can always unwrap
and roll the
the the inductive equation in classical
with the red updates right and in this
case the probability of using some
action i is going to be proportional
to e to the eta
to the summation
of all of the utilities from time
i up to t minus one
of u i of t
right
all right
so tau up to t minus one okay so what
does
optimistic multiplicative with a bit
does is that like it takes the last
the last utility and computes and it
takes into account twice so it actually
adds this
ui of t minus one
so
the last day payoffs
are taking into account twice
okay
and that's exactly what the minus
here is coming to fix
okay since everything is is taking into
account twice so this is like you know
the utility of the first action at time
one plus the utility of the second
action at time two
plus three times
uh a time the utility at time three
now i have to subtract this once sorry
two times time three so i have to
subtract this one right and then i have
to add twice
ui at four
right
okay makes sense
oh my god yes okay
wow this is this is a first
okay
all right so but hopefully now that
makes sense right great so like somehow
you give a little bit extra
extra boost on the very last piece of
evidence and somehow it makes sense it
gives you a little bit of efficiency
bias
right to the payers okay
all right so like now the thing that's
like really surprising it's like totally
non-trivial to see
is that
okay in this this uh optimistic somehow
tweak allows for much much stronger good
guarantees in general games
okay so as i said like the assumption if
i'm gonna uh
you know can be described as
the state of the system tomorrow will be
identical to the state today okay
resulting in this slight efficiency bias
okay
and uh and of course the optimistic
assumption can be applied for all
different kind of ftl dynamics
but the main thing that we'll be
focusing on is multiplicative weight
updates okay and as i said
optimistic multiplicative weight updates
is just the standard multiplicative
weight updates with the pair of
contributions of the last period counted
twice
and here's like two seminal results in
this area yes
so you're talking about regret bounds in
games yes
yes
does it achieve no regret in the
standards yes it also it seems very good
so
uh it's not exactly
i mean
yes
it also like achieves good regret
guarantees in
in the online setting as well okay but i
would say that
i mean if there's no opponents there
will be no change over time right now
one thing like by me there's no opponent
there is uh so there are two different
settings in the online setting
your player vector comes from the from
the environment there's no control
whatsoever
they actually provide
like some linear background grantees
for the online learning setting okay
but the thing that they're particularly
stronger
is that they're able to break this the
first this first is out with the first
algorithm to actually break the square
root of t regret bound
and get like little low of square root
of t regret
uh
using uh which actually showed
uh
or you get of c to the one over four
okay in general games
and then uh actually
because this and kothers
like showed the
exponential improvement
over this uh t to the one over four
bound and now
the the current best regret boundary we
get is is
log to the fourth power
okay and again this is in general games
and uh somehow like the the real
game here this is exactly the same
algorithm the slightly different tweak
is it is the choice of the decreasing
step size
like a careful adaptation of how the
step size decreases in a very careful uh
like accounting of the errors
like allowed for this like exponential
improvement over regret in general games
okay
uh but now actually we want to go even
stronger right we're actually going to
go
like we want to remove the dependence on
time all together okay
so
uh
and actually there's a very interesting
question which was somehow in some sense
it doesn't even feel like a constraint
that we should be using advancing step
size it feels somehow like very very
natural right
so actually all of the previous
state-of-the-art methods in terms of
like proving like really good
uh good guarantees they used the
exploited the ability of like
fine-tuning your regret uh your step
size
and sometimes like it makes a lot of
sense to use a decreasing step size well
first of all it makes sense historically
all the results that we know online
leveling that use it's necessary to use
the decreasing step size but also for
the reasons we just saw the beginning of
the slide or the beginning of the talk
right so if you take a decreasing step
size then in the limit the algorithm
looks like an od
so it's easier to control errors
and actually the system becomes more
more predictable and stable but if
people like move like very very slowly
then somehow like yeah maybe an
algorithm looks more like an od okay so
maybe it's less surprising that we can
get good regret guarantees okay
but actually there's also like a reason
for trying to move away from decreasing
step sizes right
and it has to do with uh somehow that
okay uh if you keep decreasing this the
step size and the limit goes to zero
well in the end somehow like you're not
really learning right so
your your learning rate your adaptation
just becomes negligible
right so it's like it's it's a i mean it
allows you for like you know very very
strong
let's say theoretical bounds but in any
practical machine learning system like
you really want to get everything out of
your system right so every time you run
an update you really want to gain
something in terms of performance right
so how do we do that how do we
get uh around this issue
right
and then here's the the key idea somehow
on one slide
is that well you can actually
create such systems
such that the revolution is perfectly
predictable which what you want
but without stability that these
agents can learn very aggressively
okay using large step size different
steps possibly
okay but they can actually predict the
future which is really what you care for
okay you don't care for stability
right you care that you know actually
what happens tomorrow
okay and then here's like two
different uh physics nobel prize winners
and first says okay predictions are hard
says newsborn especially about the
future right so this is somehow like the
online learning world right so like it's
it's impossible to really predict the
weather right
but you can actually
although the future cannot be predicted
sometimes you can create the future
and if you can maybe explicitly
create the future so that it's
predictable
okay so that's the
that's the thing i want to try to do
and actually here's the the algorithm on
one slide and it's really somehow it's
so simple that
yeah that is that yeah the algorithm
itself is trivial so what is what's the
only difference between clairvoyant
multiplicative weight updates and the
actual vanilla multiplicative with
updates is it like what is the vector of
payoffs that you see
okay
so if here i had so remember this is
the utility for our for agent i for
playing action si okay
and this of course depends on
everybody's behavior okay but now i'm
saying like your time t
look at everybody's behavior at time t
plus one
in the future
and then plug in those pairs
okay
now i'm saying like okay so so if this
goes from t to t plus one
then you go from the multiplicative
weight updates to the clear volume
multiplicative where the bits are good
okay
and as i said like this is the important
thing here
and somehow like the the non-stardom
thing in at least
in this type of literature is that
the time t plus one appears on both
sides of the equation
so typically this is just something on
the
on the left hand side and then
these are all the things that we already
have seen in the past
but this is actually a fixed point
equation
it says find
some vector of
mixed the profile that actually
satisfies this equation okay
right so that's the
that's a formula okay
so
uh yeah and as i said like the
observation here is that like
in some sense we're we're taking this
idea of optimism and we and we applying
steroids yes
so just
in order to
calculate this
i'll get there yes yes i'll get there
i'll get there yes yes
all right of course this is this is
we're going to be all it's all about
calculation but right now let's just
build intuition
uh this is proximal point method right
yes so i mean
so the approximate one method here this
is
holds methods of
uh
unconstrained optimization
but as we see okay so computing this
with large with large step size eka
is going to be ppad hard
so i don't see how
let's see how the proxy car
method at least this is the way i also
see it okay but the question of like
what okay whether you can have an
equivalent formulation
does not does not somehow for sure yes
yes
so the thing about okay so we still no
matter how we decide to pull this right
so this raises the question a bunch of
like questions that we are going to
arise in the next slide right for
example like does this make sense
i mean i can write this whenever you add
such an equation
like does it even have a solution like
why is that
it's not it's not obvious that this is
true okay
but as i said like this idea here the
intuition behind this is that
you want to form uh
confirming self-confident predictions
about what all the other players will
play tomorrow
right so this is what you think people
will play
because this is what you actually plug
in to compute your payoff vectors
and this is what they end up playing as
a
result
and these two things are green
okay so
and that's somehow like the the
you know
the the reason for like calling this
clairvoyant is because in some cases you
know what will happen tomorrow
okay
all right but now actually we we come
with a bunch of like the the meat of the
paper is actually now starts now okay
so all right you can write all these
things this is great
but
there's a bunch of questions well first
of all okay what is the regret of this
kind of like formula
like why does it have any any good
properties right
second one and and this is kind of like
that's more important well does this
even make sense
so is it always the case
that this fixed point
equation
always admits the solution
and what i mean by admits a solution
remember like this is
it takes a bunch of parameters the
parameter is the current vector of mixed
radius for all agents
and the current vector of
of learning rates for all agents and i'm
saying like take any game
take any mixed strategy
and take any
vector of learning here it's no matter
how large like you know infinity oh
nothing sorry 10 to the 100 okay
can you prove to me that even with this
huge somehow like learning rates this
thing admits a solution okay if not then
you know the fact that you written down
doesn't it's meaningless
okay
but of course you know we're not
mathematicians here so it's like proof
of existence is not enough and actually
this is like a fixed point problem like
we're always actually worried very much
worried that six point problem is
something like ppid
hard and in fact
this computation would be ppid hard
if the learning rates eta become very
very large
okay there's no
there's no efficient way to do this
but
we'll show that as long
you can always choose fixed
step size as long as your fixed steps
are not too large
then
this
this fixed point equation admits a
unique solution
and you can compute this efficiently in
linear time via contraction mapping
argument
okay so and finally which is again uh
this is something that
that actually uh
uh
yeah sergio actually talked a little bit
about you're like okay we're in this
sort of like game setting
so it better be the case that i can
compute this kind of like updates
like us agent i without knowing as agent
georgios without knowing let's say raf's
payoff
payoff matrix or like payoff vector okay
so i'm going to be able to do this all
of this in decentralized way you know
and the answer to all these questions
will actually be positive okay and
that's
and and i'm going to go in the rest of
the talk in terms of like how does does
this work out
okay
any questions here about the
statements
okay all right let's uh
let's move forward
all right and
yes does it make sense to think of this
algorithm in the online setting
no a great question i mean you can't but
you have to be god
because like literally here you have to
know the future
right so yeah so it doesn't make sense
or it or the only way i guess
i mean maybe i'll touch upon this a
little bit so one way of thinking about
this algorithm in the online setting is
that it reduces to actually optimism
because the only thing you can do is
just compute the first possible update
like you're you know you cannot solve
the fixed point calculation but you can
start your best possible guess right now
is what is the one that
that the optimism actually uses
actually this will be part of the
computation so i'll get to that
okay so yes
so
this algorithm
xt plus one is for all the agents and so
you're it's a centralized computation of
you know knowing the future for
everybody
yes correct correct so this is the this
question yeah this from every agent i
will actually complete exactly the same
so yeah so
the the whole fixed point calculation is
a bunch of
such equations for every agent and
straight to national foreign
well that would be a great question
we'll just jump to it so like okay let
me just say that like if
eta becomes very very large that goes to
infinity this fixed point becomes an
arbitrary good approximation of mass
it becomes an absolute match okay so now
i'm going to say like okay of course
like you're never going to be able to
compute this right
but the thing here is that like with
fixed but not large epsilon
okay and sorry but as long as this is
not too large
then this would computation would be
extremely efficient
unlike nash
okay and the thing like this would be
enough for constant regret
okay that's the difference
uh okay so let's let's start first with
the
regret type of arguments and actually
therefore the greater our arguments will
it's actually easy to do it not just for
uh the levojan version of multiplicative
with updates yes
i'm sorry
you're probably going to touch on it so
if so just tell me
but can you go just to the previous
slide
so
here
i will have to solve this problem
not only relative to my future strategy
so it is not
x i t plus one and everyone's current
strategy
x i t
it is not vi of x i t plus one
x i x minus i t
right
so
here i will have to i i will have to
solve this kind of
fixed
but also the strategy of all the other
players would be uh
to take into account somehow the future
strategy of everybody
this is totally unsolvable
yes so actually it has like a very
strong
uh like mass
again
and actually you know in a way that i
want that you can interpret this as an
exact mass of a of a different type of
game but i don't get there
okay but the thing is like this you can
do you control the official
yes yeah
okay let's let's move forward okay so as
i said like actually you know like i
feel like a little bit uh you know
like large like you know like i'll just
do the proof for regret for not just for
clairvoyant multiplicative with updates
but for all of their dynamics
and then what's the the the natural
analog is that okay when i do this when
i create this memory register in my mind
like i just uh you know i always add to
motor's payoff in my vectors right
so i see the future and then i just
solve the standard like remarks problem
but now you know i have a choice of my
regularizer okay
and the claim here is that you can
actually should
have a universal upper bound on the grid
for all regularization steps either
okay
and uh the proof uh and here's the upper
bound on the regret
so it's actually the range
for its age and i
i have my regularizer it's the range of
the values of the regularizer divide by
the step size
okay and now here's where i said that
the larger the step size the smaller
this this number but this number is a
constant
okay for example
if i have multiplicative weight updates
because the regularizer is the entropy
right so the max entropy
is log of the number of actions
the minimum of the entropy is zero
so it's actually log
of the number of actions over over eta
okay
okay so how
what's the proof sketch here behind this
this proof
is like okay i know the future thinks
it's very easy when you know the future
so
if all players are clairvoyant then
effectively
follow the regularized leader is not a
is a b deleted algorithm
so middle of the algorithm is when you
actually can see one step look ahead
okay
and there's actually well-known
straightforward induction arguments
to so that that if you can know the
future then your regret is not negative
for
for this be the leader kind of
algorithms
the only difference here in the case of
clairvoyant
uh
ftrl is that like you have an extra
period
corresponding to the regularizer course
that you're optimizing over that you
don't really care for
okay but that's okay like this is you
can take it on the other side of this
regret computation and this is what that
contributes to this uh uh
constant term okay
so effectively this is the proof yes
sorry where did they come from
so this
right so this is so remember every
player has a
statement convex regularizer so for
example this would be the negative
entropy
right and then this regularizer is a
function over the space of mixed rights
information
so this has the maximum and minimum
value yeah but
if you drive it to zero
yes
and if eta goes large then you can turn
this to zero
okay
okay yes what's the boundary because you
said it that could not be true yes okay
good we're getting there okay so so
but they're jumping
and say it's the foreign
i can set air to be 10 to be a million
okay
and now i'm making you an amazingly good
guarantee
i'm saying you regret
totally good for your time including
your total regret on the very first play
can be arbitrary small
but you have a name for something that
has such a product of mixed strategies
and has a very very small regret it's
not it's an approximate nash equilibrium
okay so indeed
if eta becomes very sm very very large
what you're computing on the very first
day is an approximate nash
so the computation
will become pretty hard but i'll go
around this okay
so all right so going to the real
question
okay uh well actually you should have
another question that's a brief question
to this like why do i even have a
solution
okay i have not even guaranteed to you
that
that
this fixed point equation could have no
equilibria whatsoever
okay
or it could also have multiple
equilibria which is like less bad
but in this case i would have to solve
the equilibrium selection problem okay
so here's the the first statement
for the case of clairvoyant
multiplicative weight updates
for any vector
of learning rates no matter how large
ridiculously large
the
this set of equations always admits the
solution so i can always like these
things exist but you know you cannot
necessarily find them in
fast okay
but
if the step size is not too large
okay
then clairvoyant
will have a
a unique solution
and actually
you'll be able to compute this in a
linear time
contraction mapping kind of argument
okay
so that's the
that's the idea okay how do you prove
this so the first one is how do you
prove that
for any set of learning rates this set
of equations admits a solution
then effectively this is
an application of brower's fixed point
theorem okay i won't share the exact
details but as actually
again said you
like showed before i will give you an
alternative and equivalent formulation
of browse fixed point theorem which
exactly was particularly useful for this
specific kind of problem okay
and this is known as the poincare
miranda theorem
and it's a generalization of the
intermediate value theorem from a single
function in one dimension to multiple
functions in n dimensions okay
so what is the intermediate value
theorem says like
suppose i have one continuous function
and here it takes value minus one and
here it takes value plus one and there's
some point which takes value zero
okay
so now this theorem says like okay
consider ends as functions which are
again continuous okay
but here's the important thing okay
so let's say the the again
the variables are run from minus one to
one
okay
and
uh the fun each function f i
at one end when x is the in the negative
part it's always constantly negative
and in the other edge it's always
constant positive
okay
then if that's if that's true
then there is a point in this
n-dimensional now hypercube
where all functions now simultaneously
become zero
okay this is like a very non-trivial
thing that actually
this is actually true okay and i'm
claiming in a it's also like
it's not trivial because it's as i said
formally equivalent to browse fixed
points here okay but uh
i mean and then
effectively the proof is is a careful
application of this uh
uh
of this theorem
oh yeah so that means
but anywhere for when when set
it means the following so like
if i
minus one
x minus one
is always
less than zero
right so
okay so it's sine is fixed
yes for all
[Music]
all right so
okay so and then but as i said like so
it's a fixed point theorem effectively
so you could have many fixed points
number one number two as i said it's
actually formal equivalent you need to
do pd hardness
so you need a totally different proof
to get a efficient computation
okay
and here's the idea
the idea here is like i'm going to
define the following map
so the map is effectively computes
the update rule
of multiplicative weight updates
but now it takes as an input
uh
it takes as an input like a vector of
pairs
ui right
and
i'm going to use a banach fixed point
theorem
to prove that this
map
as a function
on the space of mixed as the profiles is
a contraction
okay
so what this means okay let me see what
it means so this is a function that
expects in
a profile of mixed strategies
for all agents if i have a profile of
mixed search for legends i can compute
these utilities
by looking at like what happens in the
space okay
but now i'm saying like okay and then
this function spits out
another vector of mixed strategies
okay now i'm saying like this function
on the space of
products of mixed strategies is a
contraction okay if you prove this then
you're done
because uh
you know you have clear trivially
uniqueness of the equilibrium but also
efficient computation
okay so and uh
and here's maybe at this point i can
finally answer
uh
a good case question how large can the
step size be
right and then uh okay don't
like uh okay so
for some notion of
the details are not so important so for
this notion of for specific notion of a
of a metric
like you need this product of
eta so eta is the step size of the
algorithm
v is the payoff range so the preference
is from zero to v
so think of v equal to one if you
normalize payoff okay to be in the zero
one right and then n minus one is the
number of variants
you know i'm saying like is this product
is strictly less than one
okay
then you have the contraction map
so that's what you want you know you
want
uh reformulating you know the steps as
eta
cannot be too large it has to be smaller
than this constant but then i can just
plug this constant in my generic
bound and get this
total bound on the total regret okay so
totally get is
logarithmic on the number of
actions linear on the range
and effectively linear
and minus one on the number of players
okay
that's it
let's see the uh that's the actual
like totally great bound
okay
and then
there's the question the very last
question is okay i've i've showed
existence uniqueness
and efficient computation
but okay in my proof like it cannot
compute this without
me knowing ralph's payers okay
and because uh yeah and indeed you can
you can do this okay you can do this as
follows yes
oh yeah so so because this is a
contraction map
the distance like contracts
exponentially faster
right
yeah
right
so okay so here is
all right so so how do we compute this
listening in practice somehow in a game
theoretic world okay so each players
now will start with an estimate
of what they should play at time at the
next time period okay
and let's say the initial estimate is
like okay maybe
i should play
what i actually played in the last time
period
okay so this is my what like somehow
stationary kind of assumption but now
i'm going to plug this
hypothesis to compute my vectors of
pairs
and this will give me a new
guesstimate
about what i should play actually
tomorrow
and what here's what i said like what
optimism does
it
it stops here
he says i'm happy
okay i did this one day look ahead i'm
happy i'm gonna plug this in okay but
now it's like no no
broadcast these results okay
let's say put it on a you know
put on a blockchain
so that everybody can see right now
everybody can see you know if if the
system has stabilized
if that we're happy
plug it in and done
if not do another update
okay
but the important thing here is that
this update rule
like i need to know nothing
i don't need to know your step size i
don't need to know i mean i only but
that only depends on myself
okay
on nobody else
it
yes
the
strategies from previous route because
so
you say
so i have to plug something in here
actually i can plug anything
because the map is a contraction mod
whatever plug gain you have to converge
to the unique fixed point
of this map by the contraction proof
what i'm saying is that like okay like a
reasonable thing to do just to keep the
analogy with optimism is to plug in what
people played in the last figure
okay
and then what i want to say is like
optimism does exactly this
okay to compute what is the
next strategy digestion plate so it
preempts this behavior exactly once
and then it just spits out this behavior
okay so that's that
all right so that's what i'm saying here
okay uh
and um okay and the main thing i want to
say is like let's let's okay this is
like a nice proof what about the proof
of the padding comes into the
experiments
okay
yes sorry so just a test understanding
what you're basically saying here is
everyone
plays multiplicative ways
fictitiously like
without actually
committing to the strategy we just i'll
simulate products for some number of
rounds yes exactly that's exactly what
i'm saying
yes
but sorry actually i think i'm coming
ahead of your question because you're
that's fine
so i just want to be clear about the
uh the computational overhead of this
so uh if if i were running uh
let's say vanilla multiplicative wait in
order to do my update i just need some
oracle to give me the mixed payoff
vector right so one oracle call one
update okay so here
uh
i'm starting with the initialization so
that's one oracle
and then assuming that your eta is
sufficiently small
so as to have a contraction right we'll
have this with this fast
approximation of your
clairvoyant strategy but this will
require a logarithmic
uh
algorithmic number of working calls okay
but right right exactly the reason the
reason i'm asking is that if we have so
in terms of oracle calls
which is the standard
uh
which is the standard uh
metric reported in pre-regularities
this actually inflates each iteration
by a logarithm
and my worry is that when we aggregate
all these logarithms
we will end up
with a number of oracle calls which is
logarithmic in the time in the horizon
so
even though in terms of iterations i can
understand that your result gives you
uh locally it gives you constant regret
in terms of iterations place
if we compare apples to apples and we
compare oracle calls
i failed to see how this process will
not give you
regret which is logarithmic in the
number of oracle codes all right so my
answer to this is the point
is that uh okay so
we uh i agree so this is this is a call
or this is i guess uh we got accounting
here in regards in terms of like one
such fixed point computation i think
but due to the
so
as we saw in the simulations here we
won't have any like uh somehow uh
like let's say we're gonna use like 64
bits or you know of of accuracy let's
say for this for this problem
distribution
so actually you can
confuse and actually like up constantly
upper bound
on how many iterations you want
on each sides loop
such that you actually compute
like uh
an approximation of the fixed point of
the computer accuracy
of the or the fixed point calculation
okay
and then like this okay we'll create
like a trace of error
okay that that
that can increase but both integration
complexity will be very very low in
practice and the practical event will be
extremely low
and that is why i won't show an
experiment
okay
so i agree i agree with your points okay
but let's let's put apples to apples
actually i am going to put apple
stoppers comparison here in terms of uh
in the in the next slide
okay so here
i have multiplicative weight updates
the vanilla formulation with the
one over square root of three decreasing
step size okay and here's like how the
regret
grows with time okay
this
is the previous state of the art
the paper by christie cental
right where gives us the polar gary
think regret okay
and here
is the actual regret bound for
clairvoyant again and see like here's
the actual
uh you know here's the actual
experimental performance here's the
actual theoretical bounds
and here and uh the here i'm going to
say like
the the solid line is the mean
and then the actual like the rest
is the range for the range taking over
random initializations of the game okay
and this is not a toy game so this is a
game that has you know like uh
say four-star four-player strategies so
this is somehow like has ten thousand
uh strategy profile yes
so in uh when you solve the inner
problem
clearly your problem yes
so you are not able to solve it exactly
correct
so
do you take this into account like do
you have to solve it
better a better and better way as the
number of iterations increases okay
that's a good that's a good question
okay so i have two answers to this
so when you apply
let's say multiple when you're trying to
stand up you get with updates right and
you
just compute take compute a fraction
like like just make uh you know
yeah you just divide this you know a
numerator and denominator you do like a
small error right
so you compute the actual extraction up
to computer accuracy right so i want to
say like what is the analysis of like
how you you keep track of that error in
the class coming to look at the weight
updates
okay
again why not
so
what
accuracy yes
i'm computing it exactly i'm convening
yes um is there a trade-off here between
if you have a smaller step size you're
going to get a lower contraction mapping
constant
but you're going to not achieve as much
of the regret bound what
how does that relate to convergence time
because you have to solve this big point
problem true so i mean
so but
in proprietary purposes as long as your
degree as long as you have a contraction
you know like you are going to have a
meeting going to be different constant
yeah in the rate of exponential decrease
so as you see like so let me just show
you the experiments you get a sense
of how of that indeed the number of of
uh calls from the bigger updates is
actually in fact is not all that large
yes
but i guess the more important is that
you need to
extend information to agents
uh
so you have to have a way of of
broadcasting this information but as i
said like even from a very practical
perspective you can do this without any
trusted centers right so let's say as
you say like there are blockchains you
can post the information up there we
don't have to trust anyone and this is
publicly accessible
like for
to all other agents right
so i think this is it's a real
constraint okay but i would say that and
there are some cases where this
constraint will be binding and and you
could not
do this but i would say that like there
are many cases where you can't
if this is allowed i'm wondering can you
just like at the beginning
you do some protocol like this and
compute a uh
group here then you just
create that
type but here's the thing okay so so
first of all
like the information that you give here
is much much smaller
so you just give so this is like here
you just keep a single
you know you can you just give a simple
status profile
like i'm not communicating and this is
not like just talk
you know like trying to broadcast like
they're doing for like all of your
payoff medics to somebody else right so
that would be another very realistic
algorithm i mean you could you could
argue for this but i don't think this is
like a strong argument against this kind
of technique
okay
and if you want to go around this signal
they will be able to enforce the fact
that the algorithm is decoupled
okay but i don't allow you to know what
the [ __ ] there is
can i ask something hello you know yes
yes
what is the bound on k i i must have
missed how many
do you have a bound on how many
iterations of
on the previous slide on the previous
slide yes
yes yes
so as i said like here we have a proof
that this mapping is a contraction mod
right
so given some level of computer access
that you want right
i can find how many steps
uh like the logarithm of that a computer
accuracy will give me like an upper
bound right on the number of steps up
until
like the the
this fixed point computation will
converge out to computer accuracy
does that make sense
so just think of this let me know so
here suppose like we actually have to
prove we have a truth also for the
duplicate norm right
and let's say you let's say supposedly
you set the eta so the contraction is
one over two right
so every time you apply some other
contraction mapping you actually
decrease the number like you know the
the number of this bits by one right
so this will give that an upper bound
on the number of iterations up until
you're
guaranteed to compute an approximate
equilibrium
after the desired accuracy of your
algorithm
yeah i understand that but my issue is
that in some sense each broadcast like
that is like a hidden
period of play now it's true it's not a
play it's a virtual play but
when you are counting convergence and
you are asking how long it takes to get
something you should really start adding
all the k's
the the k sub t which are the number of
sub periods you are using for every t
and that is the effective
number of periods that are needed to get
whatever precision you want okay
but uh as i said like like
let's see
that you are not playing the game i mean
you are doing it but but in terms of
computation or whatever other other ways
of doing it it's it's uh you are you are
essentially it's one period
yeah sorry right right so as i said like
my argument here is like
uh is that you can't provide bounds
like as i said like as long as you're
you're
you're okay with computing the
approximation of the computer of the
computer accuracy so if you look at this
the number of uh uh
uh calls let's say to multiple bit of
dates
in average per uh
per step uh is you know something
between like two and a 3.5 right so it's
not like a huge overhead like from a
practical perspective right
and as i said like this is something
that you can actually formally provide
like an upward bound which is constant
you know up to you know for computations
given a desired computer accuracy for
your system
does that make sense
i see so so so it's a constant what you
claim is that it's there is a constant
there yes
which
depends on the parameters that you chose
on whatever you want to achieve
yes and i'm saying that like this this
constant error is not
like crazy right because it's a it's a
price you have to pay for action with
because you had updates
because when you compute it on your
laptop okay you compute computed up to
the last
decimal digit okay but in principle
let's say if i have like you know 1 over
11 you know
you have infinite digits here
well at some point you're going to stop
right so you're going to truncate so
you're going to lose something
okay okay you could lose something okay
it's not it's not the end of the world
like if your error somehow like
propagate up to computer accuracy i
think this is something that
that both uh that
you know that you can live with
experimentalism you know
and that you have to live in any so like
you know in any
actual computer system you know you
cannot have infinite digits of accuracy
right you know you have to at some point
you have to stop
yes george uh can i ask a question yes
so it sounds like your argument's saying
that log t
is going to be constant anyways
no okay
so yeah the algorithm does not say like
log t is constant
right so the argument says the following
right so i'm saying that like when you
do the analysis of multiplicative weight
updates of its regret right
like what do you take into account that
when you compute your actual update step
in multiplicative weight updates your
update is not perfect
is that accounted in any of the proofs
you see in the books of multiplicative
weather bits
i'm sorry that if you if if your update
is not perfect okay yes so if it's
accurate only up to epsilon then your
proof can i mean the proof that you show
can only will propagate an error of
epsilon at each round so in the end you
will have
your constant regret bound
plus epsilon k where epsilon is your
machine perceived
we can say
that i'm going to take epsilon to be
very small yes
and i have to tune it
in order to make the c factor which is
next to it disappear
i'm not at all sure how long not end up
getting from this tuning an extra look
to it and one last thing
is the
if the name of the game here is do not
ignore the lottery
and
that this place this is what is
important
i'm not so sure that we can that we can
overlook uh
these type of errors that you that we're
saying because they will have a
logarithmic
impact on the performance of the
algorithm
so the impact okay so say there are some
details that next right right so like uh
okay so if we we can okay we can account
with using increasing accuracy and i
agree that that would be like an extra
glob thing there okay
uh in the in the analysis of the regret
so that i i am uh i agree with right
there but what i'm saying is that like
for any uh like this this
in a private
you know in a practical context okay
what i would just run with a fixed
precision and it's time said okay i have
these error terms that i probably gave
okay
uh but
like these terms can be
kind of like a
like a linear term that can be
arbitrarily small or slow
okay
so
does that make sense
i think we should take it offline yeah
sorry
all right right right so
uh like one thing i want to say here is
that in case of multiplicative weights
or optimistic multiplicative rates
uh
it's not even in principle possible to
get such bounce in the sense that
you can find like small two by two games
such that if the step size is large
enough
then you get trapped into
uh these algorithms have regret that
that grow linearly with time
okay and this has to do with so like
bifurcation effects
so
the dynamics can get trapped in specific
limit cycles that that lead the
lead to such uh bad regret performance
so in some sense if you wanna if you
wanna try to run
like uh learning with very very star
very large step sizes you really have to
do something like more intricate in
terms of like fixed point calculations
and
yes
because here the number of
steps in the inner loop was very small
try to compare with optimistic methods
with like constant step size yes so
that's the thing is like so this is
exactly the type of game for optimistic
method with constructed size would make
you large living area
yes yes
okay
just part of the data on the last page
uh like last night you have
you increasing the step size and the
average pulse
go down
and isn't it that as your step size goes
up you're getting a heart problem or
complete problem so your average close
friend yes but that happens of course
just in the worst case
like the worst case game i mean this is
just a random game
okay
okay uh
all right so
okay there's definitely a lot of like
open questions in terms of like
exploring different extensions right
here we just have to minimize regret but
what about internal regret and
what foreign other clustered games
uh and then of course
like the fact that we're minimizing very
good does not necessarily mean that we
understand the limit behavior as
dynamics
so for example like with in recent work
with uh raf
we show that like we can actually have
arbitrary complex dynamics
arbitrary complex dynamical behavior in
terms of the
uh
in terms of dynamics like epithelium
dynamics
and you can even never exist to get uh
undecidability
uh
results for without making questions
and uh christos actually will talk uh
tomorrow about some other negative
results for game dynamics so in some
sense like you know like the fact that
you can get something positive for it
that does not really mean that we
understand the long term behavioral
systems and gender like their day-to-day
performance which can be extremely
complicated that's a totally observant
question that's uh worth the
investigation okay that's it thank you
[Applause]
okay i think we've assailed your joes
with questions already but um maybe we
could take one or two more yes
uh thanks
so it's one thing to assume find that
that everyone's playing replicator
dynamics but this is also taking a
agreed protocol so even if everyone sees
the announcements there's still some
faith in that we're
faithfully reporting and one can if i
know that we're in a competitive
situation then i can manipulate my
announcements
perhaps to my favorite
correct so like i mean there is the
question of of
uh like i didn't make any so like uh
guarantees that like this this profile
of algorithm is in some sense an
equilibrium on the space of all
algorithms i think that there's no way
that i see that to argue that but there
is something that that you could there
is one type of adapter that you can
actually
so for example like if you say like look
we're gonna play this we're gonna play
this recursive broadcasting game and
then once i see somehow like that the
last two periods are the same then i'm
forcing you to play the game you can
actually you can actually i force you to
play this strategy not something else
this is something you could enforce be a
smart contract for example we say like
if i see
that you deviate something else i force
you to play like a huge a huge penalty
and then in some sense that could become
like a nas equilibrium okay and a second
question is one can think about going
the other way for continuous time
replicator dynamics
uh so here you gave clairvoyance to the
discrete time case
uh what if in continuous replicator
dynamics you had the opposite and say
the payoffs were lagged delayed
would it lose its uh finite regret
property
so now it's it's not clairvoyant it's
the opposite it's just it's it's a step
behind right so yeah i mean i think when
you go to continuous time you have like
like for example like i wouldn't even
know how to add this issue of
computability right so how so here i
actually you know i went through quite a
bit of thing to provide like an
algorithm for computing this like up to
some accuracy right so how do you do
that actually with an actual vector
field i think that's that's a different
set of questions maybe even a different
class of like fixed points so you have
to look into this uh you know each sets
so for example like yeah so the fact
that for example this this
fixed point computation like even has a
a solution
it's very specific to multiplicate
updates if you use another ftl that
actually doesn't say apply
so every every sats uh every such
variant needs special attention
okay
maybe one more question
maybe lunch
thank you very much for the very
illuminating talk i passed a lot of
questions i guess the thing i agree with
paranoid is that this update rule looks
pretty similar to the like the i think
exactly the same as proximal point
update with kr and also you mentioned
like the clearance you also have a
version for a folder regress leader do
you do you know that let's say if you
plug in l2 instead of kr does any of the
insights here for example can we get an
efficient algorithm for like the l2 can
we get
like the a better regret for the for the
proximal point type of analysis so the
things like r2 right uh or is that
specifically to this multiplicative
weight update so the existence of the
solutions all the items that we've shown
are very specific for multiplicative
weight updates and you actually need the
stiffness of the regularizer
okay
so like without the thickness actually
many of these results
like even the even the existence results
were actually not hold
i say so mean that if you change the
regularizer to another thick
rubberizer maybe we should still be able
to get the
constant look back here yes okay but as
i said like like you know it doesn't
work it says case like requires like you
know special attention in terms of like
each of the set of questions that we
have explored here right
yes
thank you so much
georgios by the way